fini ce que la parole est à madame laure
de la raudière merci madame la
présidente
mais je collègues ma question s'adresse
à monsieur le premier ministre le 6
octobre dernier la cour de justice de
l'union européenne a invalidé le contrat
entre la commission européenne et les
états unis
communément appelée safe harbor de quoi
s'agissait-il
cet accord passé en 2000 permettait aux
entreprises américaines telles que
google facebook microsoft cisco et bien
d'autres de recevoir d'utiliser et
d'exploiter sans garde fous les données
personnelles de nos concitoyens
européens
à l'époque la commission européenne
avait jugé un peu naïvement sans doute
et surtout sans concertation avec les
états membres que les états unis
présenté les garanties suffisantes pour
la protection de la vie privée
les révélations des north d'edouard
snowdon sur l'utilisation de nos données
par les états unis et la haine et ça
nous a apporté les preuves éclatantes du
contraire les états membres auraient dû
être beaucoup plus vigilant à l'époque
de ces négociations
j'ai l'impression que nous sommes en
train de reproduire les mêmes erreurs
dans la négociation du traité commercial
le contenu de ce traité concerne tous
nos concitoyens et nous n'en sommes pas
informés
cela concerne des enjeux économiques
majeurs mais aussi la protection de la
vie privée des français
à chaque séance de questions d'actualité
sur les sujets européens
nous soulevons l'opacité des discussions
entre la commission européenne et les
etats unis dans le cadre de la
négociation du taffetas à chaque fois
vous nous répéter que vous demandez la
transparence dans les négociations
à chaque fois nous avons l'impression
d'un aveu d'impuissance alors quand
aurons nous enfin gain de cause
quand pourrons nous donner notre avis
sur le contenu des points négociés la
france a indiqué céline rouge concernant
la négociation du taffetas mais la
france ne peut rien seule et elle est
bien affaibli dans la négociation au
niveau européen commun quand est-ce que
vous en êtes vous pour converger
appartenant
mais habitée de la nécessité d'imposer
ses lignes rouges
la parole est à mme la secrétaire d'état
chargée du numérique
merci madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les députés madame la députée
laure de la raudière la protection des
données personnelles de nos concitoyens
c'est là un droit fondamental
fondamentales auxquelles ce gouvernement
est particulièrement attaché un chapitre
du projet de loi pour la république
numérique est d'ailleurs consacrée à ce
sujet nous sommes l'un des gouvernements
en europe les plus impliqués dans la
négociation actuelle sur le règlement
européen sur les données personnelles un
texte très attendu
et voilà des années que nous demandions
la renégociation de cet accord de safe
harbor passé entre les états unis et
l'europe qui permettait de déroger à
l'interdiction de transférer des données
personnelles des citoyens européens vers
l'extérieur je parle à l'imparfait car
vous l'avez dit la cour a décidé
d'invalider cet instrument considérant
que les programmes américains de
surveillance de masse et est
incompatible avec notre vision avec la
vision européenne de la garantie des
libertés dans le monde numérique
ce jugement il est très important tant
au plan juridique qu'économique avec un
impact potentiellement très grand il
faut maintenant que l'europe et l'europe
politique pas l'europe technocratique
parle d'une voix forte pour affirmer ses
valeurs et pour définir des outils
alternatifs avec les états unis mais il
est exclu que ce sujet soit négocié dans
le cadre du partenariat transatlantique
du type qui n'est pas transparent
c'est là une ligne rouge dans les
chapitres sur le commerce électronique
dans les chapitres sur les
télécommunications que demandons nous
nous voulons la protection des
consommateurs la neutralité du net une
concurrence saine et loyale face au
géant américain de l'internet et la
liberté laissée aux états de fixer des
règles de localisation des données de
leurs consignes
moyens sur le territoire national la
france n'accepterait pas que la liberté
et la vie privée soient bradés sur
l'autel du commerce international merci
madame la ministre la parole est à mme
chantal